let's say Pete over here thinks that
he's a pretty good investor so what he
does is or he has an idea that says look
I'm going to create a corporation and
I'm going to get a bunch of people to
contribute money to that corporation and
then I'll manage that money and maybe
I'll take a little fee for myself so
that I can maybe hire some analysts or
get some computers or some or get some
office space so what he does is he sets
up a corporation let's say he sets up a
corporation right over here and let's
say the way with the way he first sets
up the corporation let's say it just has
four shares and I'm making the number
really small just to make the drawing in
the math easy
this wouldn't be realistic normally it
would be something in the hundreds or
thousands of shares or maybe even more
than that but let's say it has four
shares and let's say all of the four
shares are owned by Pete initially just
to simplify the explanation and he puts
in $400 $400 into this corporation so
another way to think about it in
exchange for him putting $400 into this
corporation he gets four shares or each
share each share is worth is worth $100
each of these shares right over here and
so what he does is he registers this
corporation and I'm talking about a u.s.
specific case but there's similar types
of organizations in other countries he
registers this organization right over
here with the US SEC Securities and
Exchange Commission and he also
registers himself with the SEC or even
better he registers a management company
that he runs with the SEC so let's call
it Pete Pete Inc is a corporation he
starts off that he also registers with
the SEC and when he registers with the
SEC he tells them that look this company
right over here we're going to issue
more shares for more people to
contribute money and I'm going to manage
this money right over here and I'm just
going to take a percentage of the total
assets under management sometimes you'll
see AUM use that just means assets under
management that will go to Pete Inc
every year for figuring out the best
place to invest this money and it's
usually on the order of about one
percent sometimes a little bit less
sometimes a little bit more so one
percent per year so right now with only
$400 assets for
dollars under management it would only
be about $4 per year but since he
registered with the SEC he can call
himself a mutual fund and he can solicit
funds from the public so it is a mutual
fund he has met he's jumped through all
the hoops that the SEC sets up for him
so he can mark it he can market himself
as some type of great fund manager we
don't know if that's true or not and he
can also solicit funds from the public
so from from the public and we're going
to see in future videos there are other
funds especially hedge funds that can't
just that one they can't market and they
can't take funds from the public those
can only take funds from certain types
of sophisticated investors and what
happens in Pete's fund and this is going
to be an open-ended mutual fund that
we're showing here and most mutual funds
are like that let's say that Sal comes
along he likes Pete's marketing
materials and says hey I want to I want
Pete to manage my money too so Sal goes
and he gives $100 and he and says Pete
give me a share so Pete creates another
share right over here
he creates another share he gives it to
Sal so he gets one share that's me I get
one share and then exchange I gave $100
to the fund so now the fund has the fund
has $500 so this is another hundred
dollars right over here and now Pete's
annual fee is going to be one percent of
this whole thing or five dollars a year
and if this whole thing grows let's say
this whole thing doubles to from $500
let's see it doubles to $1,000 then that
thousand dollars is essentially split
amongst these five shares now so all of
the people will essentially have their
money doubled - whatever
Pete's expenses are so let's say that a
year goes by and then even after paying
Pete the 1% so we had $500 of assets
under management
this whole assets under management a
year later goes to let's say it goes to
$1,000 so Pete either is really good or
really lucky or a little bit of both so
it goes to $1,000 so let me draw it like
this so now it is at $1,000 and it still
has the same five investors here and I'm
lucky enough to be one of them
here's the five investors let me draw
the shares so there's one two three four
five shares now each of these shares
that well the thousand dollars is called
the nav or the net asset value so let me
give you give you that piece of
terminology just means net asset value
and so there's an nav per share the nav
per share right over here is $200 I just
took the total nav and I just divided it
by the shares and what's special about
an open-ended mutual fund is that the
close or at the end of every day either
new shares can be removed from the fund
or it could be created before the fund
so in the first video I showed how I
wanted to buy into the fund so I bought
a share and that increased the nav and
it also increased the number of shares
he had to create a share for me to buy
he didn't so he didn't sell me a share
that already existed so you could
imagine after this type of performance
more people would want to buy shares so
now they would have to buy in to make
things fair at $200 per share because
that's the current nav per share so
let's say that five more people want to
buy in at $200 per share so what Pete
would do or what this mutual fund it's
not Pete really it's the corporation it
would create five new shares so one two
three four five there's only there's
only one person that day it would create
one share that day if there was ten
people that day it would create ten
shares that day and it could keep doing
this and the nav of each of these are
$200 so it gives these shares to each of
these people and they had to contribute
$200 so essentially it puts another
$1000 into the pool that Pete can now
manage and so now he's met the total nav
for the fund is $2,000 now and Pete will
get his 1% management fee off of this
entire $2,000 now let's say that we fast
forward a little bit
we fast forward a little bit to lets say
Pete starts having a not-so-good year so
let's say we fast forward a year past
that and Pete's
Pete has a minus a negative 10% return
so if you started at $2,000 and that's
when
include taking his management fee out
you start at $2,000 you lose 10% in one
year so it goes down to $1,800 let me
just in a new color so now he's at
$1,800 and it's not completely at drawn
to scale but hopefully you get the idea
so now he is at $1,800 1800 1800 dollars
but you still have a total of 10 shares
you still have total of 10 shares so let
me draw try to do my best to draw the 10
shares so I have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
these should be of equal size and now
the nav per share nav per share is going
to be 1800 divided by 10 or 180 dollars
and let's say that I get a little bit
freaked out by this recent performance
and I have some other commitments with
my money so I say Pete you need to buy
this my share back for me
so what Pete does is he would give me
back $180 so the total nav would be
would lose $180 so would go down $180 so
we would take this out of it
1,800 minus 180 is 1620 so now it is
1620 and they would buy back a share for
me so they would cancel one of the
shares but notice the nav per share does
not change by me redeeming my share it
does not change what happens to everyone
else now you have 1620 divided by nine
shares that should still get you to be
one hundred and eighty dollars per share
if I did my math right so 1800 divided
by minus 180 gets you 1620 it should
still be one eight hundred and eighty
dollars per share but this is the nature
of an open-ended fund you can keep
creating shares and selling them to the
public to raise more money or when
someone wants their money back you
essentially buy the share back from them
give them their money when you buy it
back and you remove that share so an
open-ended fund really at the close of
every trading day can keep growing or
shrinking it can keep adding more and
more investors or their investors can
take their money back what's difficult
about this from the
fund managers point of view is that they
have to manage this they have to manage
this constant buying and selling with
the public they have to manage the
paperwork and if you think about it they
can't have all of their money invested
in in relatively illiquid assets or even
in regular stocks they have to keep some
amount of their money and it's usually
like three to five percent they have to
keep some of this 2,000 dollars before
he lost my money they have to keep some
of it in cash and from an investor's
point of view they would say well if I'm
good at investing I shouldn't I should
try to minimize the amount of cash that
I have because I'm not getting a return
on cash but because it's open-ended
because investors might come by and say
hey I want my money you have to have a
little bit of cash on it as part of the
asset pool in order to be able to buy
people's shares back